alright good afternoon everybody I have
the as Diane mentioned the coveted
before lunch spot so thank you to
Allison and the organizers here there's
a study out of Israel I think this was
published five years ago maybe four
years ago that looked at parole rulings
by the time of the day and basically
showed that when you get right before
the meal break right now where the red
arrow is that basically you're just
going to go back to jail so you're not
getting a favorable ruling so I'm again
deeply appreciative Thank You Allison uh
so with that said I will try and make
sure that we keep this energized and
interesting and get you off to lunch
shortly thereafter but some of you know
Diane just mentioned that i am a new
hire at Google I I came in about four
months ago so I'm still I think
technically noogler and I came from a
traditional brick-and-mortar company 77
78 year old company fortune 300 company
lots of different properties everywhere
lots of different lines of business and
a lot of mess a lot of what one of our
customers refers to as the ugly
enterprise right a lot of just stuff
underneath the covers when you looked at
IT and there's some examples up here of
that messiness legacy applications in
some cases dating back 40 years in some
cases dating back two months right this
whole mix data silos literally
everywhere you know we had silos upon
silos and what have you and really
importantly a changing view on the value
of data there was some data that we
always knew was important and there was
other data video data for example we had
no idea what to do with the data and it
was expensive to store it so we sorted
through the data out right we didn't
store it it just was was purged quite
quickly that obviously has changed
there's a lot more that you can do with
that range of
now regulatory environments and I'm sure
a lot of you in the room deal with on a
daily basis bringing the regulator as
long as you're trying to innovate and
then really importantly cloud skills are
really hard to find and really hard to
recruit for and really hard to retain
and so this was our world i'm imagining
i expect that this is a lot of your
world to see a lot of nodding heads in
the room and by the way as i've been
getting up to speed at Google as I've
been meeting with a lot of customers I
hear this from traditional ugly
enterprises from the traditional
brick-and-mortar companies and I hear
this from a lot of folks that we think
of as startups that have actually been
evolving the way they think about their
architecture as well now the the amazing
thing for me and really what brought me
here to Google was understanding when
you can even start to make small dents
in these challenges when you can start
to pull out some of the data and really
apply some some real analytics to it
some real mature and machine learning to
it etc you can see amazing impact on
your business we managed to to bring
down costs not just IT costs but
marketing costs sales costs operations
costs we were able to grow revenues we
were able to really launch products much
more quickly and it was all due to using
the cloud to to really unlock the power
that is locked inside the organization
so as I come here to Google a large part
of what brought me here was this idea of
working with companies and really
helping them to unlock the value that is
hidden within their companies that is
just sort of trapped within these silos
as I've been focusing on the on what we
call our customer team and really
thinking about how do we work with our
customers to really maximize their
success there's three areas three
pillars that we are focusing on the
first is investing in your success the
second which ores and others alerted to
luda to earlier today is around
partnership economics and the third is
taking the partnership beyond support
into a whole new realm and I just like
to spend a couple minutes talking about
each of these different pieces starting
with investing in your success I think
Tim
nap said it just a couple of minutes ago
that that when you move into the cloud
there's a lot of trust involved right
there's a lot of trust involved it's a
partnership it's not a
quarter-by-quarter thing it is something
that really extends much longer than
that years and decades and we at Google
are really focusing on that interface
that we've got with customers and our
customer team we're hiring a thousand
over a thousand people to join the
customer team to really sit and work
with customers to make sure that it
isn't a remote relationship but it's
something that is really a personal
relationship because it is a trust-based
endeavor now really importantly for us
at Google as I've talked to customers
what they really said is help me unlock
the power of google within my company
help me get that my engineers connected
to your engineers and so as you look at
even our customer team we're actually
focused on hiring three times as many
people in the technical side as in the
non technical side because the problem
solving that comes when you can get
engineers connected with other engineers
and really start to figure out what so
the workflows look like what should the
applications look like how do we migrate
how do we get from point A to point B
with that is really powerful and it's
really dependent on having people who
want to work with customers and by the
way all of our engineers are dying to
work with customers and we're hiring
more and more who want to do this
getting them to actually sit down and
understand what's going on inside a
company it's not a new build it's not a
fresh starts or how do we help you get
from point A to point B so that's about
scaling the other thing we're doing is
really looking at the at the
capabilities that we're bringing to bear
and these are just a couple of examples
of changes that we're making a new
capabilities new muscle that we are
building within Google the first is in
office of the CTO so the thing one of
the things that I hear continuously when
I meet with CIOs and CTO is you know I
need help figuring this out I don't just
need help with you explaining to me what
Google does right I need that as well I
need to understand technically I need to
understand the security I need to
understand the the pricing all of that
but real
I also need help just understanding how
do i migrate how do I manage the the
board how do I manage our CEO how do I
deal with budgets how do I deal with all
of these issues so the idea of the
office of the CTO is to really bring
peers who are familiar with Google but
also familiar with what it's like to
work inside one of these enterprises to
be advisors to really help you with your
migration a second element here is what
we are calling referring to his value
optimization of the value optimization
teams at Google and the idea behind this
is again it's a trust-based partnership
it's a long-term partnership and it's
one that is predicated on us partnering
with you to make you successful and so
we've got teams in our customer team who
are focused on reducing your spend on
gcp not by saying please stop using us
or what have you but by actually helping
to make you more efficient helping where
we see opportunities for you to save
money moving on to different services
moving optimizing your application etc
now putting on my sales hat because they
also have a lot of salespeople this
isn't the best thing for a given quarter
but we're not in this for the given
quarter we're in this for the long term
relationship and really helping to make
you successful and the last piece which
I'll touch on later is professional
services now we had Paul from accenture
up here I want to be very clear that you
will not see a hundred thousand Google
professional services folks running
around trying to serve customers that's
not what we're in the professional
services game for what we are really
focusing on here is enable meant both
customer enablement and partner
enablement how do we actually develop
the IP it's one thing to do it
academically it's the other thing to do
it with real customers and then bottle
it up and take it to partners and help
partners understand how to actually go
to market how to actually help customers
it's about training for our customers
developers for our partners developers
etc so so these are all new skills and
new capabilities that were really
bringing to market at scale but getting
the market at scale is obviously just
one part of this and or spent a good
amount of time earlier talking about in
gcp how we've been thinking
pricing I sort of describe this as
partnership economics this is something
where as I mentioned our success is your
success and vice versa and and we would
need to make sure that we're actually
delivering our products and services in
a way that demonstrates that partnership
now one of the fascinating things as i
started this listening tour when i first
joined is people are obviously
incredibly excited by cloud there's a
pretty full room lots of people are just
interested in this concept they see the
idea they see the potential that can be
a lot unlocked by moving to cloud and
they're really excited about how quickly
the world is moving but you keep hearing
these butts right you keep hearing the
but we're kind of worried that the full
potential of the cloud is not really
being delivered particularly on the
economic side we've gotten to a place
where I don't have to own data centers
which is great where I can tap into
services on demand which is great but
you're still sort of making me figure
out how do I plan capacity years in
advance in many cases right elements
like that we think are under delivering
on the promise of the cloud and so you
can look at a lot of what we're doing
from a business model and a pricing
standpoint under this umbrella that oars
refers to is putting the cloud back in
cloud but really thinking about how do
we deliver not just technical and the
capabilities that the cloud is promised
but also the economics and the business
models that the cloud is promised and
you can see this I pulled out some
illustrative quotes from conversations
with different CIOs and you can see
hopefully how some of these hopefully
will resonate with you and we've got
some examples of the solutions that
we've put in place to try and address
some of these issues and I won't read
through each one of them I'll let you
take a quick look through them but
they're fundamentally these questions
around how do I plan how do I budget
this idea of penalty or punishment right
I customers keep saying don't punish me
for actually being more efficient about
how i'm using gcp don't make me sign up
for something that with I'm successful I
will end up missing it
overpaying for down the road and so a
lot of our of our effort on the business
side has been in trying to figure out
how do we both deliver on the
flexibility of the cloud the on-demand
of the cloud reward long-term
commitments and long-term relationship
and also take into account the total
cost of ownership right this day we
recognize this doesn't stop at the doors
of Google or the doors of gcp that when
you're looking at a cloud migration you
look at this from the context of how
much am i spending how do I manage that
that in tight the entirety of that
budget there's no CFO that I've ever met
who only cares about this line item but
you can do whatever you want on the
others right and so the focus that we've
talked about today around automation
about zero ops around no ops is really
meant to try and address that skills gap
but also to start to address the overall
total cost of ownership question and we
believe that this works it's not just
solving individual bit problems when you
add it together what we see continuously
in competitive situation after a
competitive situation is that this
approached the idea of sustained use
discounts the idea of custom VMs etc can
deliver between twenty to thirty percent
lower pricing for in aggregate across
the solution than what you see from
other cloud providers and obviously
substantially lower than many on-premise
solutions as well so we're excited by
this because we again think that this
not only is the right thing to do by the
customer and helps us build trust with
the customer but we believe that it's
the right way for people to start
migrating to the cloud and it's the
right expectation that people should
have from the cloud now all of this is
good if we can build the relationships
hopefully have you view this as a
partnership hopefully deliver the ROI
and the economics not make CFOs hate the
cloud make CIOs very comfortable with
the fact that they're operating in a
predictable environment in a environment
in which we've got each other's backs
but as we looked at that all of that
whole equation and how we deal with
customers we took a step back and said
okay what about that last part you've
deploy
you're in the process of deploying
you've actually deployed something in
the cloud you've taken a lot of risk
this is now your business is running
somewhere else how should we be thinking
about support right support
fundamentally is is historically quite a
reactive function right it's a it's if
something breaks we will fix it if
something breaks called a call center
send the email do whatever it is that
you do for support and we will dig into
the problem and we will help fix it
obviously that's important right if
something breaks we want it up and
running as quickly as possible what
we're trying to do is to take that
concept of support and really move it to
be beyond the reactive to be much more
proactive about helping to prevent
problems from actually happening in the
first place and there's a couple of
different elements of this I've talked
about professional services in training
but this really it's hard to overstate
the emphasis that we're putting on
training and certification and really
supporting our customers as they make
this journey so today we're announcing
two new certifications that we've
launched one around for cloud architects
to recognize to develop and recognize
professionals who spend their time
working on developing and building
applications in the cloud the second
which we believe is an industry first
there's around data engineer
certification how do you actually build
data solutions how do you build ml
solutions who's really been trained and
vetted to be able to do that so we're
excited to launch those pieces and then
we recognize that that the one side of
this is certifying people in advance the
other part is people like to talk to
people right there the idea of i have a
problem let me find somebody who can
help me out what that we think is really
important so we're also creating these
environments where you can get hands-on
dialogue with Google engineers not
because you've got an army of people
walking around will also help during
implementations but if you're just
working on some code or you have a
machine learning problem and you've got
a bunch of data scientists but you
really want to tap into a broader
networks or help problem-solve more
broadly we're creating this advanced
solutions lab we
is really focus on machine learning the
idea behind this is that our customers
can work with us they can send their
teams from the from our customers to sit
with google machine learning experts and
bring your own data and let's
collaboratively help you solve that
problem build the model tune the models
what have you whatever problem that
you're facing we can we can help for
take that to the next level and or at
least be problem-solving partners in
that so that's what we're calling the
advanced solutions lab about two days
ago actually I think exactly two days
ago we cut the ribbon on what we're
calling the launchpad launchpad space
here in San Francisco I don't know San
Francisco that well I'm told it's a
couple of blocks from here if anyone
wants to see it we can certainly get you
the address later on today but we did
the ribbon-cutting with the mayor this
is a space two days ago this is a space
in which developers can just come in and
meet with other Google developers and
say here's my code what do you think
here's my code I'm having this problem
can you help me think through this
problem how would I do this in gcp
questions like that that we think just
starts to foster the minus the not just
the formal interactions but also gives a
vehicle for the informal and we'll be
looking as we proved out the model here
to scale that more broadly now I'm
really excited to also introduce this
concept of customer reliability
engineering so we talked about training
and that is all about helping your
developers your partner's get ahead of
the applications that you're building to
get to ensure that we're building
reliability into those applications but
we realize fundamentally that the
applications that you're running the
workloads that you're moving to the
cloud to gcp it's one thing for us to
say don't worry gcp will be up and
running but if your app goes down
because of something that that happened
is some misunderstanding of how to use
gcp or what have you it's really not
doesn't feel very good right it doesn't
feel very good at all to say well are it
wasn't our fault it was your application
was designed poorly so the idea behind
the CR ease is we're calling them the
customer reliability engineers is that
they will actually partner with the with
the customer and look at your production
applications and and if the customer
wants it dig into the code put it
through the same production readiness
processes that Google applies to its own
applications that also run in the cloud
so you can actually have art art team
work with your team on on is the is the
application developed right for the
cloud is are your production processes
correct is your operational processes
correct if you want our pagers will go
off when your pagers go off it really is
a model of shared accountability that we
are offering to take for our customers
applications running on gcp now we've
got a great example of this after lunch
with Pokemon go that we'll talk about
and how they use series to really get
their service to where it's been so I
will we'll be talking more about this
later on this afternoon but we're very
excited by this we again think this is
something that is unique in the cloud
world and unique in in the engineering
world and we think that this really
changes the equation of trust between a
provider a cloud provider and a company
and then finally I'd be remiss if not if
I didn't talk about our partners and how
we are trying to enable our partners
networks to really focus on our
customers and help deliver solutions
with our customers 13,000 partners are
enrolled to and enlisted to help people
on Google Cloud and you can see the
names on here they range from boutique
firms to the extensors who you saw up
here PwC who's been a longtime partner
of ours and the list goes on and on
we're very excited by this this
ecosystem we recognize that that we
can't do everything that you can't do
everything and where you want a partner
we're not going to force you to work
with the partners but where you want the
partners what we want to do is make sure
that they are trusted partners of Google
that they are trained in how to use
Google Cloud that they are trained to
support you in the right way that
they're enabled to get access to Google
so that you can enable that engineer to
engineer product a product engagement
that we've been talking about
and in that spirit we are announcing two
new partner programs today as well the
first is around competency so these the
same idea around the certifications
we're really looking at our partners and
saying how do we the we can certify that
you are have a competency in certain
areas see int here is an example who we
have certified as having a competency in
machine learning and that means that you
can trust with confidence that that
Google believes that they are great
partners to work with you on machine
learning we've got similar competencies
around app development and data
analytics and we'll be rolling out more
and more of these over time and then
obviously I think Tim also from snap
mentioned managed services as really a
big part of what's going on in cloud and
we are continuing to deepen our
engagement with managed service
providers and you can expect to see more
from us on this both in hybrid
environments as well as lift and shift
types of environments so with that I
spoke quickly at the end because I'm
starting to smell the dinner at a lunch
that is awaiting everybody outside so to
recap we've got the three pillars that
we've been focusing on investing in your
success the true partnership economics
and taking the relationship beyond the
support relationship so thank you very
much